Hey everyone, it's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded during APA's Technology, Mind, and Society Conference, held in October 2019 in Washington, D.C. I was away on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague Kim Mills was a guest host. We hope you like this episode. Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that helps explain how the science of psychology is connected to everyday life. I'm your host Kim Mills. There's been a great deal of media attention focused on shootings in which a white police officer fired on a black or non-white suspect. Psychology has for years performed research to determine whether racial animus plays a role in such shootings.
大家好，我是凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna），《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的主持人。本期节目是在2019年10月于华盛顿特区举行的美国心理学会（APA）“技术、思维与社会”会议期间录制的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）担任客座主持人。希望大家喜欢这期节目。大家好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客，旨在帮助大家了解心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。媒体一直非常关注白人警察向黑人或非白人嫌疑人开枪的枪击事件。多年来，心理学界一直在进行研究，以确定种族偏见是否在这些枪击事件中起到了作用。
These studies have usually entailed having participants sit in front of a computer screen and respond to images of suspects who pop up holding a gun or a benign object such as a wallet or a can of soda. These experiments are helpful, but is there a better way to study this phenomenon so we can curb these types of shootings? I'm here today with Dr. John Tawa of Mount Holyoke College, who has developed a new and perhaps more realistic method for testing these responses. Dr. Tawa is an assistant professor of psychology at Mount Holyoke, where he studies the processes that both hinder and help race relations. He is particularly interested in relations between minority groups, such as between blacks and Asians. Dr. Tawa has found that virtual technology is a particularly powerful medium for assessing intergroup behavior. For example, in one of his studies, Dr. Tawa had participants create avatars that resembled themselves and interacted in the virtual world's second life. We'll talk in a few moments about what happened between these groups.
这些研究通常要求参与者坐在电脑屏幕前，对屏幕上突然出现的嫌疑人图像做出反应，这些嫌疑人手中可能拿着枪，也可能拿着钱包或罐装汽水等无害物品。这些实验很有帮助，但有没有更好的方法来研究这种现象，从而遏制此类枪击事件呢？今天我请到了曼荷莲学院（Mount Holyoke College）的约翰·塔瓦（John Tawa）博士，他开发了一种新的、或许更真实的方法来测试这些反应。塔瓦博士是曼荷莲学院的心理学助理教授，他研究阻碍和促进种族关系的各种过程。他特别关注少数群体之间的关系，例如黑人和亚裔之间的关系。塔瓦博士发现，虚拟技术是评估群体间行为的一种特别强大的媒介。例如，在他的一项研究中，塔瓦博士让参与者创建与自己相似的化身，并在虚拟世界“第二人生”（Second Life）中进行互动。稍后我们将讨论这些群体之间发生了什么。
So, Dr. Tawa, let's start by talking about your research into police shootings. Could you describe the design of your study and how exactly it differs from other experiments that don't use virtual reality? Sure. Yeah, I want to just say one thing that I don't intend it to be better than, like a better method than. I think that the research that you described where people sit in front of a computer has been really impactful. I mean, that's sort of, I kind of want to say that's established that that is the case that people are faster to shoot on black suspects. They have greater difficulty differentiating weapons and benign objects in the hands of black suspects compared to white suspects. And archival data, too. I mean, starting in 2015, the Washington Post started just making freely available online every record of any individual killed by the police. And that data is, the raw data is available online. And a quick analysis will show you that black and African Americans are way overrepresented in that database relative to their population.
那么，塔瓦博士，让我们先谈谈您对警察枪击事件的研究。您能描述一下您的研究设计，以及它与那些不使用虚拟现实的实验究竟有何不同吗？当然。是的，我想先说明一点，我并不打算说这是一种“更好”的方法。我认为您所描述的那些人们坐在电脑前的研究非常有影响力。我的意思是，这已经确立了一个事实，即人们对黑人嫌疑人的开枪速度更快。与白人嫌疑人相比，他们在区分黑人嫌疑人手中的武器和无害物品时有更大的困难。此外还有档案数据。我的意思是，从2015年开始，《华盛顿邮报》开始在网上免费提供每一条被警察杀害的个人的记录。这些原始数据可以在网上查到。快速分析就会发现，黑人和非裔美国人在该数据库中的比例相对于他们的人口比例来说过高了。
They're more likely than white suspects to be running or fleeing the scene when they're shot. In fact, about twice as much, twice as likely, and about twice as likely to be unarmed when they're killed. So my point here is that in some ways, what we're trying to do with VR is not necessarily approach that idea. We're sort of taking that as a basis. There's been quite a bit of research that's established that. But what VR does that's really exciting and what it has the potential to do is really immerse people in scenarios where they may experience things like, fear, physiological arousal. They may, for example, have not know necessarily who the suspect is. The suspect might come from behind them or from the side. So there's a sort of unexpected element
与白人嫌疑人相比，他们在被枪击时更有可能正在奔跑或逃离现场。事实上，可能性大约是两倍，而且在被杀害时手无寸铁的可能性也大约是两倍。所以我的观点是，在某些方面，我们尝试用虚拟现实（VR）所做的并不一定是为了推翻那个观点。我们某种程度上是将其作为基础。已经有相当多的研究确立了这一点。但VR所做的令人兴奋的事情，以及它所具有的潜力，是真正让人们沉浸在他们可能会体验到恐惧、生理唤醒等事物的场景中。例如，他们可能不一定知道嫌疑人是谁。嫌疑人可能从他们身后或侧面出现。所以这是一种意想不到的元素，
that you can't quite get from sitting in front of a computer. And then what are real interest is then within that context be able to look at what kinds of cognitive processes and what kinds of emotional processes are interacting to create bias. And so what do you find? And what is different about the brains of people when they're in these situations? Well, I do want to say this, that what we have now is some preliminary data from a sample about 45 participants. None are police officers, about half are criminal justice majors.
这是坐在电脑前无法获得的。那么，我们真正的兴趣在于，在那种背景下，能够观察到什么样的认知过程和什么样的情绪过程在相互作用以产生偏见。那么您发现了什么？当人们处于这些情境中时，他们的大脑有什么不同？嗯，我确实想说，我们现在有一些来自约45名参与者的初步数据。没有人是警察，大约一半是刑事司法专业的学生。
So it's just a preliminary sample. And I just, you know, I do want to say that. But one of the first things, we actually just completed our first analysis of that data, and one of the first things that I was interested in looking at was about how people's beliefs about the concept of race affect, how they interact with suspects in the VR. This has just been an interest of mind, what we call racial essentialism, the extent to which people think of races as naturally distinct from one another and as biologically or genetically different from one another what we're seeing in other research is that that belief set is really
所以这只是一个初步样本。我只是，你知道，我确实想说明这一点。但其中最先的一件事，我们实际上刚刚完成了对该数据的首次分析，我感兴趣观察的第一件事是人们关于种族概念的信念如何影响他们在VR中与嫌疑人的互动。这一直是我个人的兴趣所在，即我们所说的“种族本质主义”，即人们认为种族之间天生不同，并且在生物学或遗传学上彼此不同的程度。我们在其他研究中看到，这种信念体系确实
related to a host of really bad intergroup outcomes people are less comfortable interacting with people across different races they're less likely to make friends across races they have more difficulty recognizing other people's faces I mean just a whole whole whole of bad consequences. So yeah, that's one of the first things that I looked at was how people's beliefs about race impacted their shooting decisions. And here's one of the interesting things about behavioral research is that you have so many ways to operationalize outcomes. So this one in particular is something that's been done in those previous studies, which is just to look at reaction time. How fast are people, when a weapon or a benign object is drawn, what's the amount of
与一系列非常糟糕的群体间结果有关。人们在与不同种族的人互动时不太自在，他们不太可能跨种族交朋友，他们在识别他人面孔时有更多困难，我的意思是，有一大堆糟糕的后果。所以，是的，这是我观察的第一件事，即人们关于种族的信念如何影响他们的开枪决定。行为研究中一个有趣的事情是，你有太多的方法来操作化结果。所以这个特别的实验是之前那些研究中已经做过的，也就是只看反应时间。当武器或无害物品被拔出时，人们决定开枪需要多少
time it takes them to decide to shoot? So what we're finding is that when you look at how people interact with the black suspects, that there is a significant correlation between beliefs about race as distinct and quicker reaction times. So the more people think of other races as distinct, that leads to quicker reaction times, but only towards black suspects. When we do the same thing with white suspects, at the moment, we don't have any correlation. That's kind of amazing. But what you're saying then is that you're really not testing with police officers at this point. It's just an average citizen, in a sense, and finding similar reactions.
时间？我们发现，当你观察人们如何与黑人嫌疑人互动时，关于种族是“截然不同”的信念与更快的反应时间之间存在显著的相关性。因此，人们越认为其他种族是截然不同的，这会导致更快的反应时间，但仅针对黑人嫌疑人。当我们对白人嫌疑人做同样的事情时，目前我们没有任何相关性。这真是太神奇了。但您所说的是，您目前并没有在测试警察。从某种意义上说，这只是普通公民，却发现了类似的反应。
So is this something that maybe could help an average citizen understand what's happening in these police shootings? Is it used, is the information useful in that respect? That's right. I mean, it is my ultimate goal is to be able to do this with police officers, and that's something that's in the works now. And yeah, that's the ultimate goal. But is this useful for civilian or non-police officers, I think? Absolutely.
那么，这是否可能有助于普通公民理解这些警察枪击事件中正在发生的事情？这些信息在这方面有用吗？没错。我的意思是，我的最终目标是能够对警察进行这项研究，这目前正在进行中。是的，这是最终目标。但这对平民或非警察人员有用吗？我认为绝对有用。
one of the reasons that I've in the past been interested in racial essentialism is because I'm an educator and to me that's something that you can just teach. You can just teach people that this is not what race is. And presumably that should have all types of positive effects. Now in the past I've studied things like interactions with diverse others. This is the first time I've really gone into something as, something, you know, specifically related to police violence. But yeah, absolutely.
我过去对种族本质主义感兴趣的原因之一是因为我是一名教育工作者，对我来说，这是你可以教给人们的东西。你可以教导人们，种族并不是那样的。据推测，这应该会产生各种积极的影响。过去，我研究过与不同背景的人互动等课题。这是我第一次真正深入研究与警察暴力特别相关的事情。但是的，绝对有用。
So how prevalent is this notion of racial essentialism, the idea that race is something biological or genetic? That's a great question. And I can just tell you what I know from a study that I did using, I'm going to call it a national sample, that might be a little generous. It was a sample I collected on Craigslist, basically, targeting major cities in the U.S. The purpose was to get outside of a college student sample.
那么，种族本质主义的概念，即认为种族是生物学或遗传学上的东西，有多普遍？这是一个很好的问题。我只能告诉你我从一项研究中了解到的情况，我称之为全国样本，这可能有点慷慨了。这是我基本上在Craigslist上收集的样本，主要针对美国的大城市。目的是跳出大学生样本。
And to try and get a racially representative sample with age diversity, education diversity. So I ended up with a sample of close to 600 people and asked them a series of questions about, their beliefs about race and not just the question do you think race is biological or not it's it's sort of a call it like a depth of essentialist model so that the the sort of deepest level of essentialism is what we call speciation or the idea of people thinking that races are actually different species or that they different races have their own atom and the for example, that was one item on this test, or the idea that races represent different departure points on the evolutionary scale. So deep level of essentialism. That item in our quote unquote national
并试图获得一个具有年龄多样性、教育多样性的种族代表性样本。所以我最终得到了近600人的样本，并问了他们一系列关于他们种族信念的问题。不仅仅是“你认为种族是生物学的吗”这个问题，这是一种，我称之为“本质主义深度模型”，所以最深层次的本质主义就是我们所说的“物种形成”，或者人们认为种族实际上是不同的物种，或者不同的种族有他们自己的亚当，例如，这是这个测试中的一个项目，或者认为种族代表了进化阶梯上不同的出发点的想法。所以是深层次的本质主义。那个项目在我们的所谓全国
sample, that item was endorsed by about 25% of the population. That's amazing. Where would people get that idea? Don't they understand what species are? I mean, I can answer that myself. I guess we don't teach science very well. Sure. I have a thought about that, but let me just kind of scale it down a little bit because the sort of less depth, how you say it, the sort of less deep beliefs were probably endorsed more. So I want to make sure that's clear. Just basic beliefs about what we call genotypic essentialism, the belief that you could, for example, determine somebody's race just looking at their bone structure or through an autopsy, or just by looking at genes or DNA, that was endorsed by about 50%.
样本中，大约25%的人口认同该项目。这太惊人了。人们从哪里得到这个想法？他们不明白什么是物种吗？我的意思是，我自己可以回答这个问题。我想我们科学教得不好。当然。我对此有一个想法，但让我把它稍微缩小一点，因为那种深度较浅的，你怎么说呢，那种深度较浅的信念可能被更多人认同。所以我想确保这一点很清楚。仅仅是关于我们所说的“基因型本质主义”的基本信念，即认为你可以，例如，通过观察某人的骨骼结构或通过尸检，或者仅仅通过观察基因或DNA来确定某人的种族，大约50%的人认同这一点。
Wow. Yeah. Yeah, I mean, where do these beliefs come from? You know, I mean, this is something that I've thought a little bit about when you take surveys, is it a belief or is it, is it like an empty set and then somebody gives you a statement and you hadn't thought too much through it? but it sounds right. I mean, if that's true, I think that's still impactful that somebody could look at a statement
哇。是的。是的，我的意思是，这些信念从何而来？你知道，我的意思是，这是我在做调查时思考过的一点，这是一种信念，还是说，它就像一个空集，然后有人给你一个陈述，而你之前并没有太深入地思考过它？但这听起来是对的。我的意思是，如果这是真的，我认为这仍然是有影响力的，某人可能会看一个陈述
like different races originated at different parts of the earth. And you hadn't thought it through ever in your life. And then you say, yeah, I think that's true. I mean, that means something too. But that's a little bit different than kind of actively promoting it. So that's one thing that's sort of unclear. But I'll tell you that, you know, I'm 42 years old. And the reason I'm telling you that is,
比如“不同的种族起源于地球的不同部分”。而你一生中从未深入思考过它。然后你说，是的，我认为这是真的。我的意思是，这也意味着什么。但这与那种积极推广它有点不同。所以这是一件有点不清楚的事情。但我会告诉你，你知道，我今年42岁。我告诉你这个的原因是，
to say that when I was in eighth grade, I remember my science textbook telling us about the three races. Where did you grow up? In Western Massachusetts. Yeah. And in reading that there were Mongoloids, negroids, and kakazoids, and as somebody with Japanese heritage and white heritage trying to understand where I foot in. So I guess what I'm saying is, I mean, I don't think I'm that old for you, too.
想说的是，当我在八年级时，我记得我的科学课本告诉我们关于三个种族的事情。你在哪里长大的？在马萨诸塞州西部。是的。在阅读中，有蒙古人种、尼格罗人种和高加索人种，作为一个拥有日本血统和白人血统的人，试图理解我属于哪里。所以我猜我想说的是，我的意思是，我不认为我对于你来说太老了。
But that's what I was taught explicitly. And yeah, that, that, that, so those beliefs were explicitly taught. And then, and then I think we kind of entered like a colorblind era where we just weren't supposed to talk about race. But, but, but we didn't undo those kind of deeply rooted beliefs that I think people held. So when you look at that, when you looked at that question about racial essentialism, demographically or in terms of race and ethnicity, who tended to believe more in the idea of essentialism? Was that white people believe that more?
但这就是我被明确教导的内容。是的，那些信念是被明确教导的。然后，然后我认为我们进入了一个“色盲”时代，我们只是不应该谈论种族。但是，但是，我们并没有消除那些我认为人们持有的根深蒂固的信念。所以当你观察那个关于种族本质主义的问题时，从人口统计学上，或者从种族和民族的角度来看，谁更倾向于相信本质主义？是白人更相信吗？
People of color believed it more? How to split up? People of color in my samples so far, I've had stronger levels of racial essentialism, but it disappears when you control for immigration status. So what I think that might imply is that growing up in a more homogeneous environment, might actually promote those ideas.
有色人种更相信吗？是怎么划分的？到目前为止，在我样本中的有色人种有更强的种族本质主义水平，但当你控制移民身份时，它就消失了。所以我认为这可能意味着，在更同质化的环境中成长，实际上可能会促进这些想法。
And yeah, that's the most sense that we can make out of that. So can you talk a little bit about the research that you did in second life and how you pitted or had people create avatars and then pit against each other? Right. This is sort of my first, like, attempt to use technology to study, to say try to study behavior as it's happening rather than relying on self-report or you know survey and and so in for that study I had people create an avatar in the program second life which is a free more people are familiar with with the program Sims but it's
是的，这是我们能从中得出的最合理的解释。那么你能谈谈你在“第二人生”中做的研究，以及你是如何让人们创建化身，然后让他们相互对抗的吗？对。这是我第一次尝试使用技术来研究，试图在行为发生时研究它，而不是依赖自我报告或调查。在那项研究中，我让人们在“第二人生”程序中创建了一个化身，这是一个免费的程序，更多人熟悉“模拟人生”（Sims），但它
similar to that, except that all the users are online. And so you can create an avatar that looks relatively realistic, and then you can interact with one another in these virtual environments. And so one of my, I would say theoretical interest is in terms of how perceived competition for resources creates dissension, particularly between minority groups. It has a little bit of an asymmetric effect
与之类似，只是所有用户都在线。所以你可以创建一个看起来相对逼真的化身，然后你们可以在这些虚拟环境中相互互动。所以我的理论兴趣之一是关于对资源的感知竞争如何产生分歧，特别是在少数群体之间。它有一种不对称的影响，
in that it impacts my own. minority groups more so than each minority relationship to the dominant group. And so, um, so when people feel like they're competing for resources, they think of resources as zero sum. So more for me means less for you. More for you means less for me. So what are the, the resources in second life? Well, what we had to do is model it, right? So what I did was I had people create these avatars that look like themselves. They would interact in these groups of about 20 at a time. And then in some conditions we called like a utopian condition. Actually, they weren't competing for any resources.
即它对少数群体自身的影响比每个少数群体与主导群体之间的关系更大。所以，当人们觉得他们在竞争资源时，他们认为资源是零和的。所以对我来说更多意味着对你来说更少。对你来说更多意味着对我来说更少。那么“第二人生”中的资源是什么？好吧，我们必须对其进行建模，对吧？所以我所做的是让人们创建这些看起来像他们自己的化身。他们会以大约20人一组的方式互动。在某些条件下，我们称之为“乌托邦条件”。实际上，他们没有竞争任何资源。
They were just told that at the end of the study, somebody would be randomly picked for a $300 stipend. On the other hand, sometimes what we did was we incur, we said that, well, your job is to kind of assemble a team of people that you think are the most intelligent and hardest working. you're trying to form a business group to simulate this economy. And in the end, the team, the people that form the strongest groups like that have a better chance of winning a $300 gift card. So now suddenly you're interacting with people a little differently because you're evaluating people for how intelligent you think they are, how hardworking you think they are. And it dramatically changes how people interact with one another.
他们只是被告知，在研究结束时，会随机抽取一个人获得300美元的津贴。另一方面，有时我们所做的是，我们说，好吧，你的工作是组建一个你认为最聪明、最勤奋的团队。你试图组建一个商业团体来模拟这种经济。最后，组建最强团队的人有更好的机会赢得300美元的礼品卡。所以现在你与人的互动方式有点不同了，因为你在评估人们的聪明程度和勤奋程度。这极大地改变了人们相互互动的方式。
maybe relying on stereotypes, even in the virtual world. And so what we saw, one of the things that I liked about doing this in a virtual environment is that second life is everything's on a grid, like an X, Y coordinate grid. And so you could look at actually physical distances between people and how those distances changed over time. And what we saw was that when people were competing for resources, it was the black and the Asian participants that gradually over time moved away from each other. But when they weren't competing, actually the black and Asian participants moved closer to one
也许会依赖刻板印象，即使在虚拟世界中也是如此。所以我们看到的一件事，我喜欢在虚拟环境中做这件事的原因是，“第二人生”的一切都在网格上，就像X、Y坐标网格。所以你可以观察人们之间的实际物理距离，以及这些距离随时间的变化。我们看到的是，当人们竞争资源时，黑人和亚裔参与者逐渐随着时间的推移而远离彼此。但当他们不竞争时，黑人和亚裔参与者实际上彼此靠得更近了。
another. And that wasn't actually true about how they moved in relationship to the white participants. So how did they move in relation to the white participants then? There was, let's see, in the resource competition condition, they, let's see, everybody moved away from each other. It was not linear. Let me just say this. So basically what happened was they, in the resource competition condition, there was a,
这在他们与白人参与者的移动关系上并不适用。那么他们与白人参与者的移动关系如何呢？让我们看看，在资源竞争条件下，他们，让我们看看，每个人都远离彼此。这不是线性的。让我这么说吧。所以基本上发生的事情是，在资源竞争条件下，有一个
there was like a coming together. People approached one another. Were they like forming groups in order to succeed? I think what happened was happening was they were like kind of scrutinizing one another. And then it had like this adverse effect where then they pulled apart. So, you know, it was a U shape. If you look at it over time, they would kind of come close together and then they would
就像一种聚集。人们接近彼此。他们是为了成功而组建团队吗？我认为发生的事情是，他们就像在审视彼此。然后它产生了这种负面影响，导致他们分开了。所以，你知道，这是一个U型。如果你随着时间观察它，他们会靠得很近，然后他们会
pull apart. And so that U-shaped pattern was true for everybody, but it was just significantly stronger for black and Asian participants in relationship to one another. In the utopian condition, this is what we called it. Actually, there was still a gradual, it was more of a gradual movement away, but actually the black and Asian participants in particular had a gradual movement towards one another. So what does this tell us about?
分开。所以这种U型模式对每个人都适用，但对于黑人和亚裔参与者之间的关系来说，它明显更强。在乌托邦条件下，这就是我们所称的。实际上，仍然有一种逐渐的远离，但实际上黑人和亚裔参与者特别地逐渐向彼此靠近。那么这告诉了我们关于
real life. Yeah, that's a great question. You know, that maybe in those cases, there's actually a sense of affinity between minority groups that, you know, the way we modeled these scenarios, what we always had, we tried to model white numeric dominance by always having about twice as many white participants. You know, so you'd have a group of 20, you'd have 10 white avatars slash participants, five Asian, five black, about. Yeah.
现实生活中的什么？是的，这是一个很好的问题。你知道，在这些情况下，少数群体之间实际上可能存在一种亲和感，你知道，我们模拟这些场景的方式，我们总是试图通过总是拥有大约两倍的白人参与者来模拟白人的数字主导地位。你知道，所以你会有20人一组，大约有10个白人化身/参与者，5个亚裔，5个黑人。是的。
And, you know, when there isn't competition, one possibility is that there's a sense of affinity that you are people of color together, your minority group members together. And so there was sort of a sense of camaraderie. As soon as there's competition, suddenly, you know, especially if you think about the way we worded the instructions, like you're trying to find people who are intelligent and hardworking. That was purposeful. That's sort of tapping into these what we call model minority stereotypes of Asian Americans. So suddenly people are, you know, it's really interesting to look at the chat logs because we've, and we've written about this, there's evidence that people are
而且，你知道，当没有竞争时，一种可能性是存在一种亲和感，即你们是有色人种在一起，你们是少数群体成员在一起。所以有一种同志情谊。一旦有了竞争，突然间，你知道，特别是如果你考虑到我们措辞指令的方式，比如你试图找到聪明和勤奋的人。那是故意的。这某种程度上是在利用我们所说的亚裔美国人的“模范少数族裔”刻板印象。所以突然间人们，你知道，查看聊天记录非常有趣，因为我们已经，我们已经写过关于这个的文章，有证据表明人们
kind of in a coded way trying to find out if people are Asian because you don't always know. I mean, it's an avatar, right? So, so, hey, who speaks foreign languages? Oh, yeah, what language do you speak? Really interesting. And then suddenly the ones that speak Chinese or Japanese are people are drawn to them. Right. So now in the resource competition, you have you have two groups who are stereotyped really oppositional where Asian Americans are stereotyped as being intelligent and hardworking and African Americans are stereotyped as being unintelligent and lazy. And so suddenly you have an idea set that is pulling two groups apart. And it's just interesting to see it in the in the behavior.
以一种编码的方式试图找出人们是否是亚裔，因为你并不总是知道。我的意思是，这是一个化身，对吧？所以，嘿，谁会说外语？哦，是的，你会说什么语言？真的很有趣。然后突然间，那些说中文或日语的人，人们会被他们吸引。对。所以现在在资源竞争中，你有两个群体，他们的刻板印象是非常对立的，亚裔美国人被刻板印象为聪明和勤奋，而非裔美国人被刻板印象为不聪明和懒惰。所以突然间你有一个正在将两个群体拉开的观念集。在行为中看到这一点很有趣。
When you watch one of these social events, they were only 15 minutes, by the way, when you watch one, you know, because we did, we would watch them as the participants were interacting. You really can't see anything. And I remember when I was doing the study thinking, like, maybe kind of a bust.
当你观看这些社交活动之一时，顺便说一下，它们只有15分钟，当你观看一个时，你知道，因为我们确实会观察参与者互动时的样子。你真的什么也看不出来。我记得我在做这项研究时想，这可能有点失败。
But they were significant. When you, you know, when you actually look at the, you know, at it, at a really acute behavioral level, there is a gradual increase or decrease that are significantly different than the racialized patterns of movement, I should say. Yeah, yeah. So is there an application for this? Or, you know, how would you translate this for some other researcher to use or take it into everyday life? I mean, I think of a couple of directions that we've gone in terms of trying to make it more applicable beyond this particular study. We recently published in behavior research methods.
但它们是显著的。当你，你知道，当你真正观察它时，在非常敏锐的行为层面上，有一个逐渐的增加或减少，这与种族化的移动模式有显著不同，我应该这么说。是的，是的。那么这有什么应用吗？或者，你知道，你会如何为其他研究人员翻译这一点，或者将其带入日常生活？我的意思是，我想到了我们已经采取的几个方向，试图使其不仅仅适用于这项特定的研究。我们最近在《行为研究方法》（Behavior Research Methods）上发表了文章。
It's a secondary data analysis from that very data set. But what we were interested in doing was trying to figure out what kind of metrics of intergroup behavior you could derive from what we call spatio-temporal data. So you have data where people are interacting in a physical space over time. And in this case, I mean, it's like people are interacting within meters of one another over seconds because we're recording data at every second. So if you have that kind of data, what kinds of movement patterns can you determine from them? That's a little bit more nuanced than just say moving away or moving towards somebody. So what we actually did was we created overhead still videos of how the nodes moved in relationship to one another.
这是来自该数据集的二次数据分析。但我们感兴趣的是试图找出你可以从我们所说的“时空数据”中推导出什么样的群体间行为指标。所以你有人们随着时间在物理空间中互动的数据。在这种情况下，我的意思是，就像人们在几秒钟内就在彼此几米范围内互动一样，因为我们每秒都在记录数据。所以如果你有那种数据，你可以从中确定什么样的移动模式？这比仅仅说远离或靠近某人要微妙得多。所以我们实际上所做的是，我们创建了节点如何相互移动的头顶静止视频。
And from and did like a qualitative observational analysis. And from that we determined, for example, we had one movement pattern, which we called seeking behavior where people would kind of bounce around between small groups. Then the next step was to operationalize that with a formula. and and then see how that metric predicted things like intergroup anxiety, for example, like on a survey. And so that paper that we just put out has a series of four different types of movement. There was a leadership style of movement, a seeking style of movement, a we call it, like homophily or diversity style movement, you know, in terms of people interacting with people unlike them or like them.
并进行了定性的观察分析。从中我们确定了，例如，我们有一种移动模式，我们称之为“寻求行为”，人们会在小群体之间跳来跳去。下一步是用公式将其操作化。然后看看该指标如何预测诸如群体间焦虑之类的事情，例如在调查中。所以我们刚刚发布的论文有一系列四种不同类型的移动。有一种领导风格的移动，一种寻求风格的移动，我们称之为“同质性”或多样性风格的移动，你知道，就人们与不像他们或像他们的人互动而言。
And in a way to operation, like people who kind of avoided social interactions, right? And so anyway, the hope is that that's general enough that if anybody has data that is recording spatial locations between people across time, that these. would be you could use those formulas and measure those four things and see how they you know so so that's one one application the other is that I've been I've been doing this for a while is actually as a teacher I've been using second life in my psych of racism in cross-cultural psychology classes because it's an opportunity to like walk in someone else's shoes right right like so if you're white, you know, use this Asian avatar for two hours in second life and see what it's like,
以及一种操作化方式，比如那些回避社交互动的人，对吧？所以无论如何，希望这足够通用，如果任何人有记录人们随时间在空间位置上的数据，这些公式就可以用来测量这四件事，看看它们如何，你知道，所以这是一个应用。另一个是，我做这个已经有一段时间了，实际上作为一名教师，我一直在我的种族心理学和跨文化心理学课程中使用“第二人生”，因为这是一个像穿上别人的鞋子一样走路的机会，对吧？所以如果你是白人，你知道，在“第二人生”中使用这个亚裔化身两个小时，看看那是什么感觉，
what experience is like. Yeah. What do the students say? Well, I get both. I get some students that it's a really unique opportunity that's unlike nothing else. If we have time, I can give you a brief example of that. I had a student. He was a white student. He was a white student. He's a French international student. He's white. And he was assigned to use a black avatar. And he was in a, one of the things that they had to do in this assignment was they had to go to a pub. It was called the Blarney Stone pub. Of course. Yeah. And it was purpose. And it had a lot of like Irish decor. It was like, you know, I picked it because it had, it would be like a very kind of obviously white context. And so he was in there as a black male and there's a band playing.
那是什么体验。是的。学生们怎么说？好吧，我两者都有。我有一些学生认为这是一个非常独特的机会，与众不同。如果我们有时间，我可以给你一个简短的例子。我有一个学生。他是一个白人学生。他是一个白人学生。他是法国国际学生。他是白人。他被分配使用一个黑人化身。他在一个，他们必须在这个作业中做的事情之一是他们必须去一家酒吧。它叫“布拉尼石酒吧”（Blarney Stone pub）。当然。是的。这是故意的。它有很多爱尔兰装饰。它就像，你知道，我选择它是因为它会是一个非常明显的白人环境。所以他作为一个黑人男性在那里，有一个乐队在演奏。
So what that means in second life is there's actually people on a stage that are being run by users somewhere in the world. And I don't know how they're doing this, but they're playing music. And then the other thing is, yeah, yeah, yeah. And the other thing is that you can tip the band, like you can give money to the band. And so my student is writing about this in a reflection paper. And he's saying like, oh, you know, I was like, well, I'm not going to tip them because this is like, it's not even my account. this is a class project you know professor tower gave me this avatar there's no money in it um and then he's like oh well so are people thinking i'm not tipping them because i'm black oh right so then he
所以在“第二人生”中这意味着实际上舞台上有由世界某处的用户运行的人。我不知道他们是怎么做到的，但他们在播放音乐。另一件事是，是的，是的，是的。另一件事是你可以给乐队小费，就像你可以给乐队钱一样。所以我的学生在反思论文中写到了这一点。他说，哦，你知道，我当时想，好吧，我不会给他们小费，因为这就像，这甚至不是我的账户。这是课堂项目，塔瓦教授给了我这个化身，里面没有钱。然后他就像，哦，好吧，所以人们是否认为我不给他们小费是因为我是黑人？哦，对，所以他
kind of just goes with it and he has this whole kind of insight that nothing has to happen you know that that that's part of the minority experience is that things don't have to happen for it to be taking up headspace and and troubling you you know and i really like that um He shared that because that made me think like, okay, that's not something you can get from like showing a movie about like minority struggles or something like this. You know, so I was really, you know, so I had some, okay, so you ask me how to students react. So that's those were kind of the best, you know, from a teacher's perspective. But there, yeah, some students just kind of like, this is not realistic. It's ridiculous and, you know.
某种程度上就顺其自然了，他有了一个整体的洞察，即什么都不需要发生，你知道，这就是少数群体体验的一部分，即事情不需要发生就会占据你的头脑并困扰你，你知道，我真的很喜欢他分享这一点，因为这让我觉得，好吧，这不是那种通过放一部关于少数群体斗争的电影之类的东西就能得到的东西。你知道，所以我真的很，所以我有一些，好吧，你问我学生如何反应。所以那些从教师的角度来看是最好的。但那里，是的，有些学生只是觉得，这不现实。这很荒谬，你知道。
Wow. It's not realistic, but right, right. But there are some elements. I mean, yeah, it's interesting. So going back for a moment to the shooting experiments that you did, were your results markedly different from what happens with the traditional test where you sit at a computer screen and suspects pop up? Well, so they're markedly different in the sense that we're approaching analysis
哇。这不现实，但对，对。但有一些元素。我的意思是，是的，这很有趣。那么回到你做的枪击实验，你的结果与坐在电脑屏幕前、嫌疑人突然出现时的传统测试结果有显著不同吗？好吧，所以它们在某种意义上是显著不同的，因为我们正在以一种完全不同的方式进行分析。同样，它与其说是关于“是否存在偏见”，不如说是试图找出“什么预测了偏见”。对。所以与其只是试图看看，开枪时间是否有差异，不如说是各种认知和情绪因素预测了偏见。正如我所说，我们目前所处的位置是，我们已经观察了这个关于种族的信念集。我们还观察了我们所做的事情之一，我们连接了一个生理设备来通过心率变异性测量压力。这是我们看到的另一件事，当人们感到压力时，压力与对黑人嫌疑人的更快反应时间之间存在相关性，
in a completely different way. Again, it's less about is there bias and more about trying to figure out what predicts bias. Right. So instead of just trying to see, is there differences in shooting time, it's like what are the various cognitive and emotional things that predict bias? And as I said, where we're at right now is that we've looked at this belief set around beliefs about. race. We've also looked at one of the things we do is we attach a physiological device to measure stress through heart rate variability. And that's another thing that we've seen that when people are stressed, there's a correlation between stress and quicker reaction times towards black
但我们没有看到同样的这种相关性发生在白人嫌疑人身上。另一件事，所以，你知道，这对我来说令人兴奋的是，这真的，这只是我们所处的位置。其他一切都在进行中，试图弄清楚，就像我们在“第二人生”中所做的那样。现在就像试图弄清楚如何做出更微妙的测量。这，这是一种，你知道，我只是，我觉得这很有趣，但我认为也有很多应用。但试图弄清楚，例如，我拥有的VR设备配备了眼动追踪。所以能够观察VR内部不同的注意力模式。然后具体来说，你知道，我们对压力和注意力模式相互作用以实际导致偏见的各种方式有一些假设。
suspects, but that we don't see that same correlation happening with white suspects. The other thing, so that, you know, what's exciting to me about this is that's really, that's just where we're at. Everything else is kind of in the works and trying to figure out much like we did with the, you know, with the second life stuff. Like now it's like try to figure out how to make more nuanced measures of things. It's, that's kind of, you know, I just, I find it fun, but I think also has a lot of applications. But trying to figure out, for example, that, that, the VR set that I have comes equipped with eye tracking. So being able to look at different attentional patterns inside the VR. And then specifically, you know, we have some hypotheses about different ways that stress and attention patterns interact to actually lead to bias.
我们看到的一件事，你知道，所以我们有数字，但我们也正在观看屏幕录像，观察参与者在这些场景中的互动。我们看到的一件事，这非常有趣，是当人们在生理上感到压力时，他们的注意力模式似乎会朝着不同的适应不良方向发展，其中之一就是变得非常混乱，对吧？所以你可以想象，如果你快速地左右看，有人从右边接近你，即使那个人因为你左右甩头而逐渐接近你，那个人实际上接近你的速度非常快。所以我们看到了那种致命的错误。但我们也看到人们在变得非常焦虑时走向另一个极端，那就是他们锁定，他们以一种有点固定的方式注视。你知道，如果你在场景早期就决定这就是嫌疑人并且你注视着，现在你某种程度上没有看到所有其他可能导致你做出正确决定的线索。所以另一方面，我们看到的是一个相当，所看到的，我只是想说明，这是观察。
One of the things that we've seen, you know, so we have the numbers, but we're also watching the screen recordings of the participants interact in these scenes. And one of the things that we're seeing, which is pretty interesting, is that when people become physiologically stressed out, they have these attention patterns that seem to go in different maladaptive directions, one of which is becoming just very disorganized, right? So you can imagine if you're kind of looking left and right real quick, and somebody approaches you from the right, even if that person's approaching you gradually because you're whipping your head around left to right, that person's actually approaching you really quick. And so we're seeing fatal errors in that kind. But we're also seeing people go the other way when they get really anxious is that they lock in, they fixate in a way that's a little bit. You know, if you just kind of decide early on in the scene that this is the suspect and you fixate, now you're sort of not seeing all the other cues that could lead you to make the right decision. So on the other hand, what we're seeing is a pretty, what's seen, and I just want to be clear, this is observation.
所以看起来，我想说，健康或适应性的注意力模式是，你知道，拥有某种灵活但结构化的注意力模式。你看到人们看着嫌疑人，你知道，然后看着他们的臀部看他们是否有枪，回到嫌疑人，向左看，向右看，回到嫌疑人。所以它不是冻结的，你知道，但它是，所以这就是，你知道，这就是我们所看到的。现在的问题是，如何在一个3D、360度的环境中操作化“固定”、“灵活”和“混乱”的眼睛注意力？这就是我们现在正在努力解决的问题。哇。你所做的事情非常非常酷。这在某种程度上很有趣。
So what seems to be, I want to say, healthy or adaptive attention pattern is, you know, having kind of like this flexible but structured attention pattern. You see people looking at a suspect, you know, then looking at their hip to see if they have a gun, back to suspect, looking left, looking right back to the suspect. So it's it's not frozen, you know, but it's, so that's where, you know, that's what we see. And now it's about trying to, how do you operationalize, fixated, flexible, and disorganized eye attention in a 3D, 360 environment? That's what we're working on right now. Wow. It's pretty, pretty cool stuff that you're doing. It's fun in a way.
我的意思是，它，你知道，我真的，我不是说它是，你知道，我，我真的，我不是说它是，只是为了好玩。我确实有一些信心，它可能非常有意义。这显然是我做它的原因。但有，你知道，我的一部分，对它感到兴奋。是的，当然，当然。你目前向警察部门提供这个程序吗？这是一个目标吗？完全开放的邀请，但我很难。我很难让人接受。我理解它。我理解它。我的意思是，它，我认为，而且，你知道，作为心理学家，我们有点搬起石头砸了自己的脚，你知道，就，你用我们的数据做什么？你知道，我明白了。所以，你知道，我对此没有任何意图。我甚至刚才在这里说过，我的，我的
I mean, it's, you know, I really, I don't mean to say that to say like, it's, you know, I, I really, I don't mean to say like, it's, just for fun. I really have some confidence that it could be very meaningful. That's obviously why I do it. But there's, you know, part of me, it's excited about it. Yeah, sure, sure. Are you offering the program to police departments at this point? Is that, is that a goal? Total open invitation, but I'm having a hard time. I'm getting people to accept. I understand it. I understand it. I mean, it's, I think, and, you know, we've shot ourselves in the foot a bit as psychologist, you know, in terms of being, what are you doing with our data? You know, I get that. Like, so, you know, I have no intention of this. I've even said here just now that my, my,
目标不是要确定是否存在偏见。它是试图确定一个人内部什么预测了偏见，对吧？所以，但这很难让人相信，我可以去警察部门说，特别是在现在。我的意思是，它，你知道，我可以去警察部门说，嘿，我能评估一下你们的警官吗，然后我不会只是拿出一份报告说这是一个有偏见的警察部门。我理解这一点。但这就是我所希望的。太棒了。
my goal is not to sort of determine if, if there's bias. It's trying to determine within a person what predicts bias, right? And so, but that's hard to trust that I could go to a police department and say, especially right now. I mean, it's, you know, that I could go to a police department and say, hey, can I assess your officers on this and then that I wouldn't just come out with some report saying that this is a biased police department. I understand that. But that's what I'm hoping for. Great.
是的。对。好吧，这一切听起来真的很有趣。所以我很感激你今天过来和我们交谈。这很有启发性。我想在“第二人生”中花点时间，也许尝试一个不同种族的化身，看看结果如何。好的。就在之前，这是一个奇怪的地方。你会看到你没预料到会看到的东西。但像许多这些事情一样，它们可能很奇怪、不熟悉且不舒服。
Yeah. Right. Well, that all sounds really interesting. So I appreciate you're coming by today and talking with us. This has been edifying. I'd like to spend a little time in second life and maybe try an avatar of a different race and see how that works out. Okay. Just before, it's a weird place. You'll see things you weren't expecting to see. But like a lot of these things, they can be strange and unfamiliar and uncomfortable.
但是的，我只是对它们用于研究行为的前景感到兴奋。太棒了。好吧，再次感谢。在结束之前，我只想说，我们希望我们的听众与我们交谈。我们对你们的想法持开放态度，所以请把你们的评论发给我们，也许是我们未来希望听到我们谈论的主题或嘉宾。你可以把这些想法发送到 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。当你们在做这些事情时，能不能在iTunes上给我们打个分？这真的很有帮助。 《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他信息丰富的播客，例如关于新心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》（APA Journals Dialogue）和关于心理学实践的《进度记录》（Progress Notes）。
But yeah, I just am excited about the prospect of them for studying behavior. Great. Well, thanks again. And I just want to say before we sign off here, that we'd like our listeners to talk to us. We're open to your ideas, so send us your comments, maybe topics or guests that you'd like to hear us talk about in the future. You can send these ideas to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. And while you're out there doing things like that, could you give us a rating in iTunes? That's really helpful. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other informative podcasts such as APA journals dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes, about the practice of psychology.
不过，我确实对它们在研究行为方面的应用前景感到兴奋。太棒了。好的，再次感谢你。在结束之前，我想说我们希望听众能与我们交流。我们欢迎大家的想法，所以请把你们的评论、或者希望我们在未来讨论的话题或嘉宾发送给我们。你可以将这些想法发送至Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。在你们做这些事情的同时，能否在iTunes上给我们打个分？这对我们非常有帮助。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会（APA）播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他信息丰富的播客，例如讨论最新心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》，以及关于心理学实践的《进度笔记》。
You can find all our podcasts on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, www.spicingsoftology.org, and listen to more episodes. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Apple、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站www.spicingsoftology.org收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。